[Musique]
dans notre village autrefois un ours
énorme dévastter le bois il faisait peur
au bûcherons et du berger mangit tous
les
moutons le maire et Monsieur le Curé
dirent en colère
cela ne peut durer C ours nous enlève
tout repos avant 8 jours il faut avoir
sa peau on partit donc de bon matin dans
la forêt qui sentait le bon pain avec
des piques des flambeaux car ce jour-là
il ne faisait pas beau nous avons marché
tout le jour et malgré ça nous n'avons
pas vu
our pourtant à la tombée de la nuit dans
un sentier on voit un œil qui luit et P
voilà monsieur le curé qui met ton jou
mais ça n'est bien tiré et l'ours qui
n'était que blessé tout étourdi roula
dans un fossé on
l'Orta à la maison et dans la cave on le
met en prison depuis ce jour abrivoisé
l'ours pas méchant joyeux et bien rasé
ce charge d'un tas de travaux à la
fontaine il va quérir de l'eau il sait
conduire le tracteur au Nouvel An il
aide le
facteur pour la distribution les prix
c'est son discours qui fut le mieux
compris et depuis siège au tribunal on
s'aperçoit ça ne va pas plus
mal tout marche mieux à la mairie ah
s'ils avaient le même ours à
[Musique]
Paris